okay for people joining this livestream
we are continuing our documentation of
new features of numbers with uncertainty
and we had done some of this this
morning we are now going on let's go
back I guess first to the page about
around yes okay
you
perhaps other we got a bunch of
background noise here good
so we were editing this I fixed the
tables and added a note where we left
okay presenting approximate number or
the value around with I think we should
take with a value around an uncertainty
presents a number with a value around
with a value around okay
approximate number around the mean of
the distribution uncertainty
corresponding to standard deviation
outside the standard deviation of the
distribution say goes
never derived I'm looking for a string
specification spec let's just say s okay
as displayed by default has an around is
used in numerical computations and
computations uncertainly why don't we
just say in computations
yeah but we still seem to have a bunch
of weird background noise I don't think
it's you Jose but okay anyway there's a
person here vacuum yeah no okay fine
it's we're hearing the vacuum so to
speak um okay
value uncertainty so what happens if so
yeah okay so if it's a list then it will
return both uncertainties um you know I
don't like the word approximate number I
think we should just say here you know
it's number interval distribution okay
okay okay in the case of asymmetry I
also have left uncertainty and right
uncertainty in case it's interesting to
extract but I mean sure it's important
to document here
yeah victims
to be specified okay that that there's
the incorrect formatting of those things
those should be a text font I shouldn't
do this that's wrong
well that's wrong so anyway then has to
be fixed yeah I will ask which one well
it's this one this font but we get that
that font and I think that's actually a
bug I think the plain text is some from
ages ago well I don't really know anyway
somebody will be able to fix that right
okay okay um yeah so there are these
first two notes there that I think they
should be move I mean they look
important to me some sort of
interlocutory well yeah I mean can be
used to represent measurement results I
don't even know what that means I mean I
mean around
can be used to represent uncertain
results of measurements as well as other
values
well subject to statistical propagation
of uncertainty No well to me the
important thing here is to set in the
stage for for for what disease which is
not numeric type propagation of errors I
say - so - can be used to represent
uncertainty in results of measurements
as well as other values where errors
where in which as well why don't we just
say what this I mean yes yes measurement
okay is to represent uncertainty
measurement uncertain results of
measurements how would these somebody's
asking on our live stream how would
these approximate must be read from
external data sources I don't think
anybody has a representation of these I
don't know of any was I've seen packages
in other systems for doing similar
things yeah okay so they have some
random representation but you could say
what that is
um ah can be used to represent um in
which there is there is statistical or
other uncertainty
okay I think we should say down here
um-hmm see this thing here I'm not so
keen on because we don't really it isn't
really correct I mean because it's only
an approximation I mean this is um it is
an approximation when the distribution
is not Gaussian when when the
distribution is Gaussian this is exact
but not when you take sine of that thing
that's not exact well it's not design
the propagation of sign from the
previous Gaussian but once we have
projected back into gaussians what we
get back is Gaussian no I understand but
if you take the square of an a round
number okay it's simply not true
that you know so if I say if I have an a
round number let's say 2 comma 1 squared
right okay great
so now here if I have a normal
distribution okay so I want to do this I
want to say X distributed codling to a
normal distribution 2 comma 1 and I want
to say how do I get the distribution of
them so doesn't the transformed
distribution of X squirt c'mon that's
okay
oh wow okay so now how do I turn that
into a round number I basically say mean
of that coma standard deviation of that
right can I can I do your can I just
wrap around around it I said you can
okay let's try it
okay seems to be a different answer
mm-hmm yes
so though this is a good this is a good
example by the way I would say yeah sure
I put that into possible issues in
relations independence and relations yes
is the thing I have prepared one yet but
but yeah I was planning to it
that is really freaking weird are you
sure it's correct well actually you know
what let's try putting a different
number in here let's say 10 plus or
minus 3
oh that's really ugly wow that's really
weird
well so much for that okay it's at a
smothering on there perhaps see up on 5
for which for this error yep interesting
yeah that is interesting
well let's let's leave this example here
I mean it's really kind of cool that
gives a non-central chi square
distribution
the interesting thing you see the linear
approximation is getting the error quite
well it's precisely the value which the
linear approximation of course it's just
n square 100 so it's not seen their
retro backward effect of the uncertainty
on day yes so for example try let's try
to do it higher order let's try here a
round replace x squared X goes to around
10 comma 1 so that will give you a
hundred but now say comma two as a third
argument which will increase the tailor
order know that the third argument in a
round replace the same
huh because we go to second order in the
Taylor expansion we get a better song we
can do it up to fourth order okay
well that's nice well that's a nice
example where yeah um I mean we may be
able to get yeah um okay someone on our
live stream is asking where the symbolic
cases will work will light yes try a
round of X comma on DX and now it's
quite that cool logarithm of that have
you have you given that example up here
yes there are so few symbolic I think
the last basic example is symbolic
that's really nice mm-hmm this is useful
to to understand what's happening
definitely I mean so if I say a round of
X DX plus a round of Y dy ok did you
give that example because that seems
like a useful example mmm but yeah yeah
anything
maybe I move it if you feel these should
until you say numerical I just say
operations on our live stream is asking
about regions with around I don't know
whether those are supported yet not yet
okay let's go back up here okay so in
what sense is the sigasi 'm I'm really
not understanding what sensitive
Gaussian it's it's a Gaussian in the
sense that the Gaussian distribution is
the only one which can be recovered
exactly from its mean and standard
deviation for the less true but okay
look around X does not um well I think
we should say around objects
computations with around objects are
performed well I mean we basically said
that with first order approximations but
I would like to say that it doesn't
really correspond to any specific
distribution I mean
objects I just don't think this is
correct I mean I think it's some vague
sense that's correct but it's not really
precisely that but if we perform
computations in which only gaussians are
involved then the computations are exact
but we just did it and it gave it a
non-central chi square distribution
because the competition was nonlinear so
there are some computations in which I'm
only a few okay okay so so why don't we
say the following for linear
computations right a round of X DX
um behaves like a number like a number
whose values are distributed according
to the normal distribution
I think that's accurate you seem to be
putting the emphasis in the propagation
not in their description of the object
before propagation well that's because
the only thing you do with it is
propagated I mean what you can do with
it with the object itself I mean the
only thing you do with it is show it a
picture where where it's showing where
you're showing intervals that correspond
that happened to correspond to one Sigma
right so imagine that we wanted to do
this type of computation of represent
the object to 2 Sigma what is the
probability of finding this other value
in this region 2 Sigma 3 Sigma etc those
are integrals with the Gaussian but I
don't believe that there are
probabilities associated with I think
it's hopeless to start saying that I
think if you start saying like you lose
the game and you're talking about
transform distributions all the time yes
and in a sense if it was possible to get
proper results from everything in in
from distribution we would do that no I
know but the whole point is there's a
calculus of these things is much
sloppier than that I think that's a good
statement I think it gives some sense of
the connection while not overdoing the
connection here can be any Americal
symbolic expressions yes will be so what
that means is that if you start with
numbers and they are exact
we wouldn't Ameri size them because
nobody wants to see an error of square
root of 2 yeah
general machine precision will be used
but higher precision may be used yes in
the in the we are casing in which
somebody has a default machine precision
will be used
okay displays with the uncertainties
showin with one
digits of the uncertainties shown um
[Music]
okay X is displayed displays we want to
do it to them so to show that X show
them of the same accuracy as DX now what
about the case where you give parens but
why don't we say with the same number of
digits to the right of its decimal point
as DX yes in a sense the parens case
it's a still these but represented in
our simpler way okay we show them to the
same number of digits throughout the
decimal point as DX how can that be
right - wait a minute
so if the DX is very precise
no butBut you're saying it's not the
same number if I say around a four comma
you know something like this right what
do you mean by so this is a case in
which there are zero digits in both
numbers to the right of the decimal
point so now try Somu by zero digits
zero at wilmut this
this doesn't make sense what we're
saying here doesn't make sense this
place with one or two digits of the
uncertainty is showing okay um X is
shown with the same number of digits
right at some point as our show one in
DX that's the way to say I think there
are sentence maybe useless which did the
very large and very small values okay
fine so now we've got this I we could
say when when DX is very small relative
to X we use this other notation with
parents okay but in my opinion these
other notation is the same plus/minus
notation but slightly different I'm not
sure how worth is to explain it in
detail
the threshold I think is in 10 to minus
6 okay um um if is typically displayed
if DX
it's very small compared to X it is
instead displayed form and form like I
think we have to just show um because
otherwise I don't see how anybody could
know what the heck it's gonna be like
mm-hm
oops that's not what I wanted to do I
just wanted to say around without
perhaps you use a number that that
contains more digits in in X one point
two three four because then it's easier
to count
Ronnie you can't remove steel so I put
six seven six seven eight okay should we
put that as a note further down
but might bond put it up there because
it's rather confusing otherwise as in
slightly weird but I don't see um I
don't really see an alternative to
saying it that way the only alternative
is not mentioning it because to me that
the notation is quite self-explanatory I
think we should mention it or people
will be totally confused okay all right
should we go onto vector around yes well
treating the X I treating the ants the X
I as having independent uncertainty or
something the uncertainties in the X is
being independent yes they are the same
like totally treating as being
uncorrelated okay it's gonna be a glitch
okay
all right should we do vector around
okay perhaps let's have a quick look at
the examples because some examples are
just in case there is something else
we're going to say hmm so with respect
to quantities
I don't think you should use random reel
here I think that's very confusing
well whatever no no it's okay I guess
it's okay so you see that in quantities
we can have the value and uncertainty
having different units and then for
example in that case because we are
going up to my limit millimeters we are
showing three digits to the right of the
n decimal point in the index oh it's
wonderful so it takes an I mean you
could even use inches and it will do
internally the computation to see how
many digits a minute what magnificent
maybe we should make a comment here how
saying come in well we could say
something about how quantities can be
used um in around X comma DX both X and
DX can be quantities X and DX can be
quantities with with the UM with
compatible units chemic wants this with
different though compatible units okay
okay well maybe we should do some easier
ones before we do vector around maybe we
should do um let's see we've got mean
around there's another one so these
folks
is pretty simple except for the fact
that there is this square root of n
dividing what's this vector around how's
it to deliver a vector around I don't
forget to do that yes because if you
have a mean of a bunch of vectors then
you want to report in there correlations
the possible correlation okay then let's
then let's document this a little
differently let's say mean of let me
just look at something um okay I think
his document a mean of X I X 1 X 2 X 3
and then a mean of X 1 1 X 1 2 X 1 3 etc
etc I see I think otherwise it's going
to be like super confusing mean around
okay gives a round object describing the
mean of the X sub I and the uncertainty
of that mean okay yep okay so now we
would say so we got several different
things to say here so now the next thing
we want to say is um in around of X 1 1
X 1 2 dot dot X 2 1 dot dot dot dot
gives a vector around object I don't
quite understand why this is a vector
around object because there may be
correlation
imagine that all these points these are
pairs is a list of pairs and they all
fall in on a line so you are interested
in knowing this type of information ok
I'm it so the mean of that would
normally be the mean of the X X 1 1 X 2
1 etc right correct
describing the correlated mean means of
the X IJ our means and correlated
uncertainties but it's not a list of
means it's only one it's only one vector
and then a covariance matrix that will
tell you information about the data and
different correlation between those
vectors I think I have an example for a
time when we use something as simple as
that
because overly-complicated here and i
think but what you're saying then is if
i say here mean around of let's say 1 1
2 2 3 3 right so this is a very
correlated case and that's why the the
matrix has the property but they're the
elements of the diagonals are always
larger than the non diagonal elements
and this difference precisely is the
correlation when the non diagonal
elements are 0
it's a non-correlated case when the non
diagonal elements equal the elements in
the opponent is the fully contracted
case
I'm confused so tell me another mean
around to compute here so if I say for
example 0 2 here yes 1 1 0 2 3 1 for
example yeah exactly so now you see how
you have a seven ninths versus two
ninths
so the correlation is much smaller okay
so how would I turn that vector around
how do I turn that into ordinary and to
ordinary uncorrelated around yeah we
will discussing this that this morning
that a round of these should you turn a
list of rounds and then and the list of
runs will be 4/3 plus minus the square
root of seven ninths and then the other
one 4/3 + minus the square root of 1/9
okay so the covariance matrix has
squares of the Sigma's in the diagonal
and the non diagonal terms describes the
correlation
people gonna go crazy having been around
gives some kind of weird victory thing
well I think it's more it contains more
information it might be useful for but I
mean arguably we should have a second
argument to mean around which determines
what this does pricing so we we get this
thing already predicted well I'm
suggesting yeah I mean I'm suggesting
that basically
I mean otherwise let's see by the way
for consistency we probably should
support mean around the distribution
even though it's going to do the same
thing as just a round of that
distribution the consistency of the way
mean works look at the second usage case
of mean distribution yes but this is
like different mean around describes the
uncertainty of the mean itself not of
the underlying distribution right so in
a sense the mean should return as the
mean plus minus 0 because we computed
directly from the mean so we know it's
exactly yeah ok fair enough fair enough
fair enough
well let's not do that so I think that
will just confuse things anymore ok
let's go back to the vector around stuff
I've still not understood why this it's
having other information so let's go to
the find to the last basic example I try
to explain what's going on here so the
idea is that we start with a multi
normal distribution and I've used the
random numbers 2 3 and then this
correlation matrix so we get a bunch of
vectors now the interesting thing is
when we compute min around we get back
something that you see this 2.6 3.7 are
an approximation to 2 3 and then these
matrix that we get back is basically the
same 1/100 by 10 sorry it's an exam 1 in
the multinomial distribution yes exactly
so by by by having more and more numbers
you can increase the 10 to 100 we get
better and better result
self to their original resort and we can
even approximate that they're reaching
out I think that should be in properties
and relations okay so so perhaps what
you have seen is that we could have a
second argument that says around and
vector around and by default is around
so which is a simpler case yes I think
that's what we should do so let's change
this okay so um now
um yeah on our live stream someone's
pointing out that we should have a sub
value for the vector around yes we go
variance yeah that's true I'm sure we
have that documented in vector around
that's worried about that on that um
okay so the first thing here I think we
just document um
so and the possibilities to separate a
mean vector around the seems to be very
very heavy I mean the case people are
gonna want here the primary case okay
let's look at this case here
I still haven't really understood them
but by the way we also have to say that
trying this in am okay we'll get to that
we'll get to vector around with
covariances in a second um okay well
that's
let's look I'm still a little confused
here so actually maybe I should look at
vector around for a minute so vector
around has these four forms two of them
stay as containers then the other two
are converted into the second one which
is the general case so the general case
is the second one which is a vector
comma a covariance matrix and this
capital Sigma is also the notation in in
statistics yeah so the the special case
in which this covariance matrix is a
diagonal then we take the square roots
of the element of the elements of the
diagonal that's the first case what the
heck is this one here yes so that's the
correlation matrix so so we have the
covariance matrix and the correlation
matrix and this is explained in the
fourth note or so certain do you think
we should be using muse and Sigma's here
well I do like the muse and sigmaz
because they they show a bit of
connection with with a statistics case
except I think that's overdone because
we don't want people to be thinking this
is a you know a fast form of transform
distribution I think we should probably
replace this with XS and DX's well and
when I was playing with the X I still
have sometimes the impression that the
fact that we are using two letters when
we have the possibility of use
so many symbols in the system it's a bit
jarring because we have DX / x and thing
Silla like light not stirred or even the
DX has some sort of differential meaning
what we call it d now that would be
better
what's a delta little Delta for you for
uncertainty I hate that let's take a
look what it looks like with them
what an Epsilon let's put
Delta all right I guess we can call it
Delta I can't change that
okay I'm just looking at it it should be
Roman now it's appearing it will look
better than if we changed it all right
okay so then then what we would do here
with vector around those are the X I
write and the Delta I yes and then we
have a capital D in there instead of a
capital Sigma I don't think that's
necessarily well um I mean yeah all
right fine or capital Delta rather it
should look better
yes represents a vector of uncorrelated
uncertain numbers with values and
uncertainties Delta I okay
okay well they don't have to be
correlated well yeah that will be the
case in which capita non-diagonal
capital deltas are zero but in general
they will not be right so we should say
represents a vector of uncertainty for
uncertain numbers with values and
covariance matrix Delta right so we're
not committing ourselves that they are
uncorrelated right now the next case is
a special case for the two dimensional
case and it's this is famous notation
using a row parameter there okay fine
seems okay we can leave it as Rao
okay okay what values are distributed
upon your multi yeah
bad bad bad bad bad yeah it's the same
situation as before okay so first of all
um okay let's go back to around here for
a second yeah so at the moment there is
no typesetting prepared for back to Iran
yeah I think it can't be case we could
use plus minus but but I don't think we
can use the parents version yeah someone
who's helpfully pointing out on a live
stream that we're using approximate
numbers rather than on certain numbers
and I agree with that
uncorrelated approximate numbers would
be better there
unfortunately not necessarily numbers
they could be they could be um um or
symbols representing numbers you mean
yeah hopefully soon we would we will
also handle dates oh boy
dates yeah XS being dates and deltas
mean quantity x exotic how we gonna
display those and around something like
Sirica this date that's extremely
advanced exotic let's think about that
for a second okay so if I say Monday
plus or minus I mean maybe it goes out
to that granularity if you say Monday
plus or minus two days what on earth do
you want to see so you're not gonna say
January 3rd plus or minus 7 or something
that would be weird
we could say X so many days around this
date
I think it's too wordy and I mean we
also don't want to use words if we can
avoid it um all right so what do we want
to say we want to say you know October
24 2018 do we want to just say whoops
plus-minus I think it's it's gonna be
what we have to do plus minus two days
they don't really see any alternative to
that and if we're doing the graying down
you know that the slight is smaller and
grayer I don't look reasonable
doesn't look perfectly reasonable um we
really didn't talk about quantities well
we did a bit I'm in a city with an
approximate if we say quantity
perhaps it will um be understood that
this needs to be a quantity yeah I know
number or quantity yeah perhaps we say
it once there
hmmm how can we alighted in these other
ones I think it's enough with saying it
once because repeating continuously
number or quantity so why don't we just
say an object with the value yes can you
sum certain object no let's not do that
an uncertain object sounds like a UFO or
something
you know what let's just set a number or
quantity here okay okay now here
a bit heavy but I think we'd probably
have to do that um okay so now I think
we want to make this statement again
vac access access to letters yeah well
I'm waiting we call it X V then we gonna
have Delta V are you happy with that I
mean X look why don't we just say V we
can just some other letter or something
for what for for the uncertainty
uncertainty victor eater okay okay can
be used to represent now what is that
the results of that
Tirzah measurements measurements of
vectors yes vector measurements in which
those statistical or other okay so now I
want to say one vector around using
computations by default propagating okay
assuming correlations within you know
taking account of correlations within a
single vector around but assuming no
correlations between different vector
arounds taking kind of
relations within each individual vector
around object correlations of values
okay all right um a round of vector
around gives results well now what do we
want to say dropping or something I want
to say this gif gives a list of of
uncorrelated around objects yes drops
take correlations of its cousin gives a
list well so we say X I gives a list of
around objects um gives a list of around
objects of by ignoring Carly
between elements and the vector around
or something yeah perhaps it's easier
just to give the formula what is the
formula if we start with vector around
of of x1 x2 and then the matrix capital
Delta this would return the list of
around X I call my square root of Delta
I hi come on come on capital Delta
that's a matrix but it might not be mi
might be this case here I see okay look
again it's a list of objects of the form
minute of around this might work X I dot
dot
um which correlations between different
values in the vector have been ignored
missing collisions okay all right now
got some fairly technical things down
here about the covariance matrix yes
it's relating the third and fourth
usages to the second one okay all right
I want to go back here um okay then
we've got this jazz here right yes okay
so let's go look at this okay so okay so
value or is that vector I'm going to
need the vector but it could be values
one at the moment I'm coordinate vector
okay
so list of central values X sub I that
correct we could say central vector as
central vector X in victor on X c'mon
Delta alright or perhaps V we were
calling to be actually we never
did V anywhere here Oh Osan you into
that wasn't a blizzard V sorry in vector
around you know why are we even giving
variables here okay alright that's that
one now what yes course from the inline
four uncertainty is covariance okay okay
so covariance matrix Delta I guess in
vector around V gamma delta okay all
right so what do the other cases here
the those don't mean anything there I
don't think but what about extracting
these other forms here we could have
correlation returning the correlation
matrix
I could have correlation okay and
distribution we could give their multi
normal distribution nice
3v c'mon I'll just give that dot too
complicated
okay okay
correlation matrix R in vector around V
comma this is not easy to explain
I would just say also dollar or nothing
correlation matrix okay okay all right
so now we need to say the same thing
here for linear computations so what's
the thing vector around V comma capital
Delta behaves I can always buy
according to the multi normal
distribution we fix like a victor become
a delta is that correct yes that's a
surprise here we've got something to add
to this vector around just like North
distribution we should add around wow
there's a lot of stuff here
okay
boy on our livestream poori people are
getting very bored on the livestream
because we're just doing documentation
but um okay pointing out but this
doesn't work yes I think the Quran is
not yet implemented but they are working
on it okay but what will we show and I
mean there's no way of showing
correlated errors right yes it's ellipse
ellipses that are tilted yes when the
errors are not correlated then the
semi-major and semi-minor axis of the
ellipse s are vertical horizontal and
when they are fully correlated they
become singular and they are aligned
okay but wait a minute wait a minute
right now when we show something like
this right are you telling me that the
vector around analog of this will have a
bunch of ellipses here yes why am i
confused here so this is showing the
range of values for each one of those
points so you're saying I
Wow imagine that we have a list of
vector arounds each one is out there so
it's always vector around their common
matrix 2 by 2 okay so each of those 2 by
2 matrices is an ellipse around the
central point described by the vector by
the 2 vector okay okay
great and so they think to so imagine
that you have an error in X and an error
in Y what you are interested is in
something like if I move to the right in
X am i moving to the two up in Y or not
if of course you know we haven't
documented this and the main
documentation here so many things yes
that yes um I wouldn't have said this is
the most obvious look what why don't we
in terms of performing operations here
why isn't it just you know a round of
you know one coma point 1 plus a round
of to common point for a very simple
thing like that makes it fairly obvious
yes but there are two sets of operations
here those involving one around and
those involving two ions no I understand
but so let's just show for here let's
just show you know log of around or sign
of around you know PI over two coma
point one or something well let's just
do exponential
okay now I think we should show here boy
this fight this is a complicated thing I
guess you've noticed that because you've
been implementing it yes many okay um
plot a list of around objects I think we
have to show how that works here because
people may not think that's possible
I think yes there's an application
example yeah I understand but I still
think we should show
[Music]
you know it seems useful to see that as
soon as people the idea that you could
do this okay let's deal with a scaled
case um perhaps further when we say in
our wrong X DX differently no I think we
should say it here scaled I don't know
what we call this you know I still like
the DX e I'm sorry but I still like
having DX I mean I think it's much
clearer
maybe I'm just used to seeing ok scale
of what should we call the Sigma I don't
know Phi around um represents number
well it represents
this it's basically a round of X comma x
times fine actually it gives that it
converts into that okay so we could say
gives gives represents a scaled number
represents a number with a scaled error
um if it's scaled out would scale
thereof I should be self-reflective
which is their standard relative error
Phi corresponding to a round of X comma
Phi times X okay now that's
true the vector around as well isn't it
hmm I'm not sure it's not implemented
yeah well let's not worry about it for
right now we got other fishes to fry
here okay
by the way does list plot has somebody
changed documentation of list plot to
include the mention of around there
you mean osos oh no not the seal says
the just the documentation of of what
list plot allows you to give us input
I've seen examples implement it no I
understand but I'm saying in the
documentation of list plot
it's a futurist so what's the future is
that does that work their intervals
probably I guess that's the reason why
the new options are called interval
markers again this is irrelevant we're
not gonna have that anymore right plus
probably they are supporting Plus - I
mean for typesetting sorry for
visualization it's so easy to support
but it could be confusing to see that
because I mean okay so so can we make
sure the visualization people go into
their other functions and go deal with
the stuff I wonder whether this has yeah
so this doesn't have the correct things
yet that needs interval yeah I was
discussing this morning after our
meeting with Brett about that actually
I'm thinking that perhaps they are
editing this function this page so
perhaps we shouldn't well I don't know
it'll be in serious okay okay hold on
okay yeah so we need to make sure that
happens
all right let's go back over here um
[Music]
okay so now I think we can remove that
note yes okay yeah and there it's a
matter of changing their the names of
the symbols right okay yeah I know which
note the one saying okay all right
vector around then goes to around around
replace multi normal distribution okay
fine okay okay let's go back to mean
around then okay so we're agreeing that
mean around by default just does the
uncorrelated case like correct yes and
think about that second argument for the
case of scalars vector around second to
make sense
are you sure hold on let me try to
understand again why this is giving back
to her around so the point is normally
oh I see well maybe we should get vector
around in this case because these are
correlated vectors and if you don't want
them to be correlated hmm what do you
think I think I like the idea of having
this second argument that specifies what
you want back what for the vector case
that's going to be useful but I think is
whether it's useful for the scalar case
no how could it be because you're going
to have it
Bishan the EXA by former distribution
they form a univariate normal
distribution and some approximation it
will be kind of useless for the Skinner
case okay given around so I tend to
think that we should leave it as it is
and then because a round of vector
around will be able to project okay
did you would have to do that if you
want give the vector around object
describing the mean of the vectors
vectors exciting I guess so yeah and
their covariance and their uncertainty
and that covariances good discover means
yes the covariance covariance singular
yes it's a covariance matrix okay all
right fine
okay so first thing we want to say okay
well net um the AH the objects X sub I
can be numbers quantities or around
objects um when there are around objects
that weighted in some way right right
exactly
um mean around of around X 1 Delta 1 dot
thought so what do we want to say
weights there is a note four of them we
can perhaps okay computes them weighted
mean of the X sub I using
what happens if there is a combination
of around and non around objects here
that case is tricky because if there are
numbers then they are supposed to have
zero error which means they would win in
there in the weights because you know
weights are inversely proportional so I
just think it that works
let's just get an error message probably
states have already it should be given
our message okay computes the weighted
mean of the X sub I with weights
proportional to 1 over Delta I squared
right no idea format correctly amazing
hey will remains silent on the issue yes
I think so it might be another choice of
errors that includes that case but the
statistical arguments always suggest to
use these weights let's just say for a
list of odd numbers or quantities
okay so this means that if we have the
vector case we can have the first
element of each vector we length the
second elements of each vector B times X
it can contain quantities so long every
moment so long as okay we've already
said that they can be yes so here I'm
just explaining that in a vector not all
components need to have the same units
and mean around of X 1 1 X 1 to the X I
1 can be quantities etc
it is with come come a quantity
compatible units can have units the X IJ
can have units yeah you could say x11 EJ
are compatible so long as the units can
be quantities so long as can be
quantities so long as the units of the
x1 J X 2j etc are compatible
okay all right to seal so around vector
around mean standard deviation
wait the data
oh gosh what happens if you give this
weighted data that work well do you have
the exact formulas there it's going to
go inside mean and standard deviation so
whatever they do this will do okay fine
where should we put this
list at the end so my toast at the
beginning I think we should put it after
maybe after total I was thinking after
mean daeviation or something but yeah I
mean in the second line in what you have
right now somewhere in the second line
um about hip mean around because that's
yet another mean what does mean filter
anyway oh it's another mean okay alright
so now we want to say in standard
deviation
arguably
should go well why should go for
covariance no a forced and forced
analyze yeah between covariance and
missing denies okay all right
by the way sorry oh we need to put in
quantity we need to put around somewhere
in there I have no clue how that last
thing is formatted okay all right now
what's next year we've got a round
replaced to go through right so this
should say more about numerical
precision should talk about probability
distributions here maybe interest
we have a page for that sorry what they
say integral interval arithmetic I
roughly have a page for that okay by the
way did Sushma join us or not no okay
okay and we remember to get these things
made into links and so on appropriately
okay so now we need a round replace you
need to look at a round replace oh boy
okay
let's say number or quantity
okay around replace right so the there
are two situations we always need to
meet the rules and then and if we want
higher orders and then the list of rules
can contain lists of X goes to around or
vector goes to doctor around that
explain occur later in a note okay all
right so what are we gonna do here for
the so this is where we need symbols and
the numbers you know well I think we
should say s 1 goes to around X 1 Delta
1 ok
well let's see how well guard say
propagates in certainty um inserts
uncertainty into X bar but it was just
this is standard word used for this
operation propagation so given that we
don't have it in the symbol all right I
I think we should use it in the in the
line leave by replacing all occurrences
of Si by around X I Delta I
okay for an expression of the form so
this is Street V now okay okay so why
don't we say first of all that they're
assumed to be uncorrelated
isn't that correct I mean yes so
different around objects by the way this
is not correctly updating this okay okay
in a round replace different around
objects are assumed to be uncorrelated
correct yes I would use different rules
X goes to around you mean SKS is yes so
the key point here is that if the
expression contains s in several places
yeah yeah no I know I know I know I'm in
a round replace
differently yeah each in a rounder place
of s goes to in around replace X / s 1
goes to around dot dot dot dot each
occurrence of S sub I of each S sub I
and X / is assumed to be identical to
have an ID to have the same value but
it's assuming that to have the same
value but the around X I okay each
occurrence of s I in X / of a given s I
in X / is assumed to represent the same
value but different are assumed
uncorrelated am i right yes though I'm
not sure about their way of expressing
the first part of the sentence so we
could say that all occurrences of Si I
assumed correlated but if they're not
only correlated they're actually the
same right they're the same value I see
yes we would say fully correlated or
well I think we should say that the same
value got the same numerical value okay
currents with given si in exper is
assumed to have the same values assumed
to represent the same value but
different around sub I okay I think
that's correct
okay okay so what north is this relating
to the rest of it with you know how does
that form you know how do we get to that
four where do we use that formula well
if we have a round replace of f of X
comma Y X goes to some around Y goes to
some around okay we'll just in a round
replace of f of X Y dot dot uncertainty
propagation
as based on the formula seems okay
okay that's fine but this was referring
to the previous former yeah
but so are we going to give oh yeah okay
um so the fact that this formula only
contains first order derivatives is this
first approximation first of all you
have to give this we have to say this
africanus like that that's broken so
around replace um derivatives yes an
exact derivatives of uncertainty
propagation involves Dorota --vs up to
order n
and that following note is let's put
this higher up let's put this here I
think that's a bit of a property it's
just a surprising thing because most
people expect that the value of the
final around will be just f of X yeah I
understand okay so here we are
okay do we want series here as well yep
and do we want finite difference
difference Delta some such other thing
is that irrelevant no I don't think so I
think serious is the important thing
okay
so I think there's an an interesting
example here showing there yes the first
one the first one shows the important
thing here with the correlation because
in the first case we have a single X
here in the second case we have
apparently the same thing but it's now
that the two ions are uncorrelated and
then the the third line shows
intermediate correlation the correlation
fact the correlation factor Rho is 0.5
if you gave zero you would be in the
second case if you gave one would be in
the first case fair enough and and this
example is a it's a comparison with
respect with replace itself in the
example further okay to see that you
cannot always use replace sometimes a
replace would do the right thing but in
other cases it will yeah it's fairly
subtle
okay all right well I think we have to
do now is to net this onto some other
pages
you had some suggestions of guys [ __ ]
in there no I saw that I saw that let's
get to those so I'm just thinking for a
second what else do we need to do here
so right by the way what are we doing
with various the famous you know like
Avogadro's number and things what are we
doing with these with these things which
actually are around numbers but we are
not we have not tethered to treated them
that way
no but Jeff is now for example in around
in the astronomy stuff so now we can get
say the masses of exoplanets and things
like that there is an example in the
page of a rod if you want to see it in
applications by the way you need to deal
with this creature obviously yes a bit
far long yeah yeah so we are going to
change this so right now he has these
properties called mass around and radius
around but now we are going to have
qualifiers and so you will be able to
say mass and then the qualifier will be
uncertainty goes to and and you can save
precision if you want precision target
numbers intervals if you want intervals
or around if you work gives you on the
run back okay
I mean I'm not sure that's the best way
to do it I mean shouldn't I mean
eventually the default for much of these
things should be around I suspect it
eventually but it's it's too soon right
given that alpha doesn't even have 12
yet yeah okay
quite beautiful so that's showing wait a
minute what what are those quantities
there so those are oh I see those are
those are the XY uncertainties exactly
uncorrelated in this case and that's why
I do see the cross and not get ellipses
okay let me just see something here so
are you telling me that vector around if
I do the same thing with vector around
it's not yet supported by the
visualization functions but but the idea
is that if there were correlations
between the masses for example imagine
that we know that large larger mass
corresponds to larger radius so then we
we could insert their correlations so
that they look like small ellipses
tilted positively meaning of course if
the planet gets bigger the radius is
going to get bigger yes right so in this
case these crosses are representing like
like ellipses which are not tilted no I
understand I understand they represent
rectilinear there several majors have
all the major minor axes of rectilinear
ellipses my question is do we know what
the visual appearance of these things
with with tilted ellipses is going to be
has somebody worked that out yet I've
seen some examples by near mile with non
tilted ellipses how do you get an ROI
seen on tilted ellipses using the
interval rendering thing right interval
markers yes perhaps there in the page of
list plot by the way here we should
really reference in the seal says we
should reference interval markers
Michael suggested that we cite the
gummed document here somewhere
okay well I don't know I don't know how
we usually do that but first let's get
thee okay so so but the default so the
claim is that by default it's gonna show
ellipsis in the case of correlated
errors right okay and the correlation is
that it is fine all right
okay let's try and finish off this off
okay so now let's see you had suggested
some things here let's go there um unit
scientific models formulas well I think
we're gonna need to do oh boy
before we even do that we've got to deal
with numbers somewhere right I mean
we've got to have well I'm a bit worried
that people using numbers intensively
will expect this to be super fast and
it's not so perhaps it's better if we
start by propagating this through
quantity
okay so
why would we put
you
we could say with uncertainty point
lists of points
you
where do we want to put this in here um
I would say in this page
it's the options that should be other
somewhere
whatever options are ya studying options
or perhaps that could be uncertainty
options for something here okay
perhaps this is better to discuss with
bright well okay well not and that would
Skype page we just made which is called
what number sweets uncertainty okay so
those ones there are two all markers and
the stiverson you know what let's just
put around and we may have to add that
to the styling section as well can you
tell Brett that we need to deal with
this also for that for the styling okay
someplace here we should have numbers
with uncertainty as I was saying I hope
in the future we can proudly put it here
but at the moment I am Not sure all
right fair enough
why what is it
that page somewhere with quantities with
uncertainty probably its own section and
we put the four functions
perhaps in for unit conversion after
that one would say before physical
quantities okay
to have this somewhere on one of these
pages I mean I agree that that's very
weird stuff there yes it's because this
is not about the representation we can
have any representation of numbers
inside their own okay all right okay
quantities with uncertainty so now um
numbers or quantities with spacer
uncertainty in computations and
computation zord we ever said was in
certainties yeah okay
so now I I don't know whether we should
put anything more than just listing them
down underneath there
you know vector around yes but she's
mentioned which for right to around mean
around and around replace
okay pretty sure those dots are wrong
maybe not okay okay
but the salute suggested scientific
models well let's see down here all
about scientific data analysis are you
suggested that scientific models ok I
agree numbers and quantities with
uncertainty makes sense there perhaps
here with Anita for functions
I could probably just give around there
and a dot out dot thanks
it's just freaking weird that that
always goes to some more general search
it's real hard okay scientific data
analysis I was put it in in our
quantities yeah yeah okay all right you
said formulas also yes because I expect
these to be one of the main applications
replacing variables in formulas by
iran's
is that thing called others so what he's
suggesting here a separate section I
think so though right now I'm not sure
sure but perhaps now that perhaps wasn't
it here I was thinking of the
application itself but I think I didn't
look carefully enough okay okay let's
take a quick look at the route guide the
belt route guide do we want anything but
yeah we probably want something in
probability theory I think we do
we certainly want to link from random
variables perhaps at the end where do we
had data computable data whether they
tell well we don't have arounds and
where the data but but um um no I'm not
sure what to put it here that's why I
didn't suggest any statistics ok well
let's take a look here so this is
probability and statistics oh boy
coming along there okay well we can link
to it from here okay let's have a
section here called error propagation
I'm not sure sir so from errors it's
possible to go to statistics now but for
my statistics going to errors I don't
see it yet what do you mean I mean so
what I'm saying here is I mean that
people looking for uncertainty I think
they would start in quantities not in
statistics okay okay all right okay then
let's just link then down here yes it
more about yes what the heck is that
yes so this is the quantity distribution
and the fact that the statistical
distributions can hand the quantities
okay let's put this in here then um so
that's error propagation and uncertainty
do we need to have the exact same name
nope not part of the rules okay yep and
I think our propagation uncertainty
should also go on this page I can't
believe that there okay let's look
of all shows up boy some other places
the miracle data for example some of
these fitting functions should
eventually return around objects
definitely where where is where is some
interval on this page it's really odd
well this should certainly have I think
we should just be that I think this is
not as findable as we would like it to
be the surrounding well hopefully with
my 15 pages yeah fair enough
um okay alright everything else here no
okay excellent alright thank you I don't
know if anybody survived on our live
stream but if you did hope you enjoyed
this some evening of uncertainty so to
speak um alright talk to y'all soon
thank you okay bye